what do you know about what's happening
inside of shanghai right now well i mean
i think i'm as informed as everybody
else's which is i'm looking at all the
twitter videos and uh and all the
articles so um
you know the specifics it sounds like
you know it's fairly similar to the
wuhan lockdown where they were
keeping people um you know in their uh
in their in their apartments i think the
thing that's um that they've moved on to
is if you're quarantined like they just
take your pet right away and and you
know there's no like
i i think they've gotten more efficient
at defining how they implement a
lockdown
and you know a lot of these
decisions that were probably painful in
the very beginning like in wuhan like
what do we do with about these pets
they've made the decision this is what
we're going to do
and um
you know it's it's basically they've got
a checklist now and one of the things
that you you
find out about living in china is
there's checklists for everything right
and you you go through the checklist and
you make sure that you hitting all the
things and and the checklist now is you
know pretty pretty involved so i think
they've perfected what they think a
lockdown should be and that's what
you're seeing in in shanghai
yeah i've seen videos of bags of cats
alive yeah in the streets i've seen
videos of dogs seemingly being sort of
killed slash immobilized slash disposed
of
which is
i think those cats are going to be
disposed of i think that's you know they
are alive but i think they're they're
going to be disposed of is is that my
the impression that i've gotten from
everything i've seen what do you think
is the reason for doing that are they
worried that they're a vector of
transmission are they worried that if
you have a pet you're more likely to go
outside and break quarantine
i i would i would imagine that it's
their vector because i mean pets can get
chronovirus so i would imagine they
believe it's a vector of transmission
you know if they're going to quarantine
the people they're going to quarantine
the pets
they don't really
you know they they can't really kill the
people although you know
uh when you look at the uyghurs
or or the falun gong you know they don't
really have a lot of problem with those
types of things but they're you know at
least at this point it's just the
animals that they're after
i saw a tweet that said 25 million
people in lockdown in shanghai policed
by drones that have facial recognition
and give orders
people who go out on their balconies
without masks are fined directly from
their cbdc accounts
yeah i mean it's awesome isn't it if you
think about it the what you know the
technology that we created in silicon
valley
and basically
you know what the chinese have
done is they've taken a systems
engineering approach to uh society right
so they wanna they wanna basically
automate how society performs
and you know if you think of it from a
manufacturing perspective for example
you know we we um talk about six sigma
and the idea is that you eliminate all
um you know anomalies and you make sure
that your you know whatever errors that
are causing systemic anomalies you get
rid of them and so
in a sense they've taken those
principles of manufacturing and using
the tools of silicon valley which are
really this ability to
harvest data and mine it and then use it
to
to
basically cancel those that are outside
that are anomalies
they have taken systems engineering and
this it
system that we built in the west and
combined it to create a way to automate
their society and and it's performance
based you do good you're rewarded you
get you know better prices you get
better treatment you do bad you're
you're canceled that's it period and so
you get your performance built in um
because everything you do
has immediate consequence on your life
just like you said with the drones like
somebody's going to come there and
they're going to charge your account if
you mess up now you know that's
something that's never existed it's it's
essentially like the concept of the
panopticon
which is a prison um that was designed
so that at any point a prisoner would
think somebody is watching them and so
what they what you find with these kind
of situations when you're always being
watched is that people modify their
behavior to ensure that you know they're
not going to be punished and and so what
they're trying to get is this digital
panopticon
where you're always being watched you
know what the rules are you know if you
break the rule you're going to be
punished and so you get the behaviors
and that's really what they're trying to
get i want these behaviors i don't want
those behaviors and i'm going to design
a system that that automatically
eliminates those behaviors yeah well i
mean with the panopticon it's kind of
like a a wheel and spoke design right so
in the middle of it you have potentially
one guard sat on a swivelly chair
and going out away from him all the way
around in 360 degrees or all of the
different cells the difference here is
that it's not
because of how scalable technology is
you don't just need to have one guard
that might be looking you could scale
technology to the point where you are
always being watched all the time right
they're actually because the ai can do
it right the precise you don't need and
the ai never takes a you know
you know a a p break and never you know
needs to get there
yeah ai is like running man it's running
in real time and so
uh i mean
when you think about it from you know
logically if you were going to take an
engineer
an engineer's approach to um political
science it's the perfect way that an
engineer would design a system because
everybody you know and there's so many
of these dystopian movies
that take this approach where you
basically just engineer society so that
everybody does what they're supposed to
i mean
it's terrifying but it is strange
uh the
lack of limits that a bureaucratic
dictatorial regime uh opens up in
technology that there are certain
areas of technology how they can be
implemented how they can be integrated
with
other uh elements
of society
that when you don't have a democracy and
you have fewer human rights there's a
whole new world of
uh technocratic overreach that can be
can be garnered
right well and and the other thing um is
that you know and and what this has
traditionally been what china has
benefited from its connection to the
west and that is
anomalies aren't always bad like you
have people that commit crimes but other
anomalies are you invent stuff you're
innovative you create new things that
have never existed before you know
people go to the moon you know you
create an iphone
these are also anomalies uh just like
doing bad things or anomaly so the
problem is
when you start to create this system
systematic approach to um you know
society
you're
you're getting rid of all anomalies
you're not just getting rid of the bad
ones you're also getting rid of a lot of
the good ones too and the way and the
reason china's been able to get away
with this is because they could just go
to the west who has the good and the bad
and take the good
leave the bad and and you know what what
you see happening as a as a consequence
of coronavirus where a lot of the
policies that you're seeing in shanghai
were implemented also in the west you
know countries in the west that are
democracies were basically taking the
same policies
that china was in terms of lockdowns and
and all of these other restrictions
and so what happens is over time and
this so china seeks to be the dominant
system in the world and then have all
systems look like it which is kind of
the same thing that the us and the uk
decided to do after the end of world war
ii we think all societies should be
democracies because not only um we think
that's the right way to go it also
protects you know our vision of the
system and that our democracy isn't
coming under threat or pressure from
those uh nations that think differently
well the china thinks the same way and
so
what it's been able to do in the two
years of the chronovirus is really
slowly begin to move democracies into
its form of thinking about the
relationship between the state and the
individual you know the state has power
over the individual and therefore the
individual should do whatever the state
says without question this has been how
the west has basically um adapted the
chronovirus and with things like contact
tracing in the west you're beginning to
see the technology be brought in to
enable that vaccine um you know
passports digital vaccine backboards
passports is another thing so i mean
you're seeing the homogenization
of the international order
in a way that's completely opposite of
how it was envisioned after the end of
world war ii um between the us and uk
what's happening with famine i've been
seeing tweets and news stories and stuff
about famine in shanghai is that true
got any idea
well i don't know if there's famine uh
so much as
at least yet so much as if you're locked
up and you can't get the food
you're gonna be you're gonna be hungry i
mean i
i lived in uh minot you know flying v52s
and we had a snowstorm one time and i
was in my house for a week
you know finally i had to break out and
go get milk and some other things i mean
i think that's what they're running into
is you know you after
there's only so much stuff that you're
prepared to do in quarantine and then if
you can't leave to go get food that's a
problem well surely the chinese
government must know that this is going
to happen right you lock people down you
don't allow them to leave to go and get
food there are certain things that you
need to do and i guess maybe as well
this is one of the reasons that perhaps
the killing of pets i'm pretty sure that
yeah vector of transmission will be one
of them but just if you have a pet
you've got to go outside to go to the
bathroom
yeah good point to have a walk so i just
think there's more and more
situations there have you got any idea
about why it is that there's some videos
floating around of the chinese
government or
their enforcement agency breaking into
people's apartments and tasing them and
taking them to sort of covet isolation
facilities i've seen some awful videos
and you never know on the internet right
you see a video and you go this could be
from
2009 during the whatever whatever crisis
yeah um but these videos that look like
kind of individual porta-potties and
everybody's got their heads stuck out
yeah um i i don't know what that is but
there's definitely videos floating
around of the chinese government
breaking into people's apartments and
and sort of tasing them and taking them
away do you have any idea what's
happening there
um i think it's i think it's all related
to hey you may have had a positive test
and now you're going to go um spend time
in the pokey um
i it doesn't surprise me for shanghai
what surprises me is you see the same
thing in australia they got the same
basically
camps where they send people to
like i can see it in china i can see it
in shanghai it makes sense to me but
when i see it happening in a in a
country that's supposed to have
you know something related to the bill
of rights and and and you know the rule
of law and you're saying hey this is
what they're instituting that's what
really bothers me because shanghai i
totally expect this kind of behavior i
remember
i remember you know
the
just the concern for the well-being of
people is different there you know i've
seen people
in the most horrid situations in china
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you